hahaha hello freak bitches Ari Shaffir
has so many stories about China we
talked about so many other things
besides the stories about China which
side we have to keep going to you about
to tell some crazy noodle story oh yeah
so they have these Street meat which is
great this is Shanghai that's what that
I knocked into the table I sound like a
fucking truck fell over outside uh yeah
Shanghai but uh they were like be
careful the meats great just there's
kebabs you pick it up they roast it give
it back to you they point three to
whatever it is or how much money yeah
you can get by with gesturing I learned
hello and thank you those are the only
words I really knew huh anyhow in
Cheshire should know how I know that
what Nihao kai-lan to show my kids watch
really Thailand oh yeah that's cool I
knew it so anyhow huh that's crazy I
could learn some shit yeah yeah since we
say shesh yeah sure sure it's like thank
you ah okay it's also used some other
way but I don't know so how do you want
gesturing I got sick gesturing really
yeah except a couple times I would like
peek about to go into like a noodle
store or something like a shop I have to
call my friend they gave me burner
phones which is nice I could use and I
was like hey how do you say noodles and
how do you say beef I'm telling both
words I'm just going I'm like what was
it I forget no man man me an is noodles
and uh one of the guys from the Matrix
movie is was the word for beef who's the
black guy for the matrix Morpheus no
okay
what's the main guy in the blows his neo
neo yeah neo yeah that's how you say
beef neo no yeah and was the other one
with the noodles Mian zan say me any AO
or neo I don't know but I said that and
then they're like they point to the
fucking menu like there's 18 things I'm
like lady come on you see me struggling
with if I'm falling like a medical beef
noodle just pick something for him
listen to just saying something what's
new saying it's the amazing racist where
if you would be like weren't the
language you fuck how's it parody
sketches
yeah ours doesn't really feel that way
ladies and gents on those are the best
part so angry you for those comments
were the last yeah fool man argue back
and forth it still goes angry angry
fuckheads so the noodles so they're
these noodles street noodles you can get
and I was advised the first day like you
don't want those and why show me this
video that I can send you right now you
can put up okay but um they are here put
your put your email here and then just
send it to me you can just send it to
yourself but uh so they get the oil what
they would do is they would go to the
sewer they would take raw sewage out of
the sewer and then boil it down the way
they'd make wax hash wax they'd boil off
the sewage and whatever was left that's
cooking oil that they would use it's
super fucking harmful and then Selda
like a lot of the street noodle guys
yeah that face is what I made that same
face they were cooking with sewer oil
bro it was going around so it's not
common but it was possible so it's not
like that's the only way they do it no
but the street places were like you run
a risk here it's cheaper oil oh my god
that source oh my god what is this
China's food production of course give
me some gutter oil making of gutter oil
give me some volume Jamie Jesus Christ
it's all in a day's work for this woman
she opens up a manhole cover and scoops
out as much slop as she can delighted by
what she finds what others might view is
revolting she sees as a bonanza she
works in the streets at the southern
Chinese city of Shenzhen a foot soldier
in China's so-called gutter oil industry
oh I seriously almost threw up
slop sizes gagged she said she's made
enough money to build a house for her
family back in her home village of girls
to the north
people are just awful she's scooping out
swamp eventually winds up in a
processing plant like this one where
it's combined with other animal fat
refuse to create recycled cooking oil
workers put the oil in barrels for
delivery to restaurants coming
quarantine Gordon how can you eat this
if you eat it it can kill you
cooking oil has long been a cherished
commodity in China where stir frying in
a wok is the mainstay of daily meal
preparation the high profit margins from
gutter oil production have proven
irresistible Chinese experts estimate
that one-tenth of China's cooking oil is
gutter oil which has been found to
contain carcinogens attend the toxins
harmful to humans gee you think ha ha ha
shit war is bad for you already knows
and among street food vendors armonica
production sites are often discovered
after people living nearby notice a
nauseating stench and alert your shit
that's really cooking of food one police
have arrested scores of people across
the country in recent years for gaining
more trade and seized thousands of tons
of the material look at these guys fake
drawing it's my eyes chopping out a
little bit
barely a swing yeah harsh penalties for
producers of tainted products
but many consumers doubt that China's
dinner tables can be completely free of
gutter oil all we can do is accept it in
our current society everybody tries to
swindle everybody else there's nothing
we can do about Wow
yeah that's a fuss gusting what that
takes discussing to a whole new level
I have never whenever you're pouring it
from the bucket you hit up go get that
soundbite no tap - I almost threw up uh
I had a look away that's the first time
I've ever had a look away on show like
yeah that's a nice cuz you knew where is
headed to someone's food dude I almost
threw up watching that so I did not have
any of the street noodles I did have a
lot of noodles though oh my god Street
noodles motherfucker man but that you
might have had some gutter oil
absolutely
I absolutely might so what the fuck man
I would like to know if you had gutter
oil I probably got a soon when I see
that when I said where was my god
probably at some gutter oil I would like
to know how do you think we could find
out when my friend was there said it was
like yeah I'm gonna eat it for a little
while you know I gotten a kick of eating
it this way before that I expose came
out yeah I had a lot of diarrhea and it
was a lot cuz you're eating shit
treating someone else's shit kid I got a
boil we put a flame under it you know
how should I know it is to me you know
what like we see like the worst-case
scenarios about China and like that did
you ever see that HBO documentary about
them selling bait I think was HBO they
were selling children like Oh like god
guys were selling like their
two-year-old children this one boy was
screaming cuz his dad sold his brother
away whoa
yeah deep dark shit and they were
interviewing the guy who sold his kid
and he was like look I didn't have any
money I had a kid I had a saw the kid
Wow yeah it's really fucked up I mean
really fucked up but to me when I see
stuff like that when I see that guy that
was saying that you know people swindle
people why don't you see the whole
gutter oil thing it's like humanity if
it gets bad if people are in a bath but
people gulls go real bad they go real
bad like apart metal eyes they don't
like this I'm not concerned with who
gets this like
don't think about it look so it's okay
that lady was telling I have bought a
house you bought a house by feeding
people shit how much shit did you have
to shovel to get your house and you have
to continue shoveling shit in order to
pay for that house like you I assume
they have mortgages over there do they
have a mortgages
she's not buying a house for cash like
showing up no I don't think so
big fucking stack of paper dude that's
insane that was pretty gross that's
beyond gross I almost threw up on a
podcast I've never done that before but
the clapping sound dude I hosted fear
factor first yeah I'm not a regular
person and I write I seen more
disgusting shit than almost any other
person who's a comedian yeah up close in
first right there and help people get
through eating things yeah no she's
never and I got nauseous from smelly
shit scooping it up and that sound made
it so descriptive yeah the blah blah I
really I got that weird tingling my
throat I know they are good controllers
Oh what is horrible
yeah Bryan Callen told me he was in
China and they were at a restaurant and
the restaurant had pigs underneath the
restaurant and running around yeah they
were like in containers underneath the
restaurant and they realized his mom
asked and realized that when you shit
the shit was going down to where the
pigs where the pigs are eating your shit
your human shit Oh gross oh thank you
bring the pigs
motherfucker that's unfortunate
Shh you think I mean and they're doing
an old-school style you're shitting in a
hole you're squatting like you were
talking about in the first pocket house
before this one will you talk old
podcast we did yeah but do you have the
podcast couple couple hours ago Ari was
talking about how you go into these
bathrooms and there's a hole in the
ground
that's your toilet so underneath that
whole pigs just square wait see this
region in Russia dude where that's a
fucking good but again that's what
happens when people just get when it
goes bad play that noise again Jamie
don't do it just play that noise alone
don't do it that's that part just queue
it up in case we need her let's queue it
up because we need
something I needed that
plop-plop-plop-plop